MARTIN OMANDER:
Wilden recently asked,
what if I want to access
my private Google Cloud
Storage from Cloud Run?
Good question.
It depends on what you need.
One, your Cloud Run service
may need to access files
that belong to it.
Two, your service may need to
access one particular Google
Doc, like a Google Sheet.
Or three, your service may need
to access the current user's
Google Docs.
In this video, let's
talk about the first one.
The other two will
get separate videos.
If you only need to
read files, and they
don't change very
often, you can simply
include them in the container.
Your code can then read
them using the native file
reading API.
If you need to both
read and write files,
or if the files
change frequently,
you can create a
bucket in Cloud Storage
and use the storage client
library to access that bucket.
If you're not using the default
service account for Cloud Run,
just remember to give
the service account
access to the bucket.
Stay tuned for how to access
Google Docs from Cloud Run.